this is the oculus rift virtual reality
headset
and now we can finally say that without
tacking on words like prototype or
developer kit because starting today the
oculus rift is finally shipping to
customers so how does it stack up well
that depends it's not a self-contained
device
it's a peripheral and it won't work with
just any computer you need a desktop PC
running Windows and you better hope that
is fraud now the headset itself is
actually remarkably comfortable not just
to wear but to deliver you VR
experiences you know I'm going to get
past that whole box on your Facebook
thankfully it feels lighter than it
actually is
thanks for some savvy ergonomic design
just don't make it too tight or after
more than about 15 minutes you might end
up with VR face inside the rift what you
end up looking at is really two custom
displays running at a combined 2.5 k
resolution but thanks to some added
magic like what we think is a diffusion
layer to smooth out any visible pixels a
lot of the dreaded screen door effect
has been mitigated since earlier
versions it's not like you don't know
you're looking at a screen but all that
visual stuff is just one small element
in a whole constellation of technologies
that works together to enable the
presence that phenomenon when your brain
actually reacts to a virtual experience
as though you're really there integrated
on your headphones might not look like
much but they deliver shockingly good
sound the entire front of the headset is
studded with infrared LEDs as is the
rear triangle and that allows the
included infrared sensor that comes with
the rift
track your headset in space what that
means is that when you're sitting at a
table in VR you can lean forward in the
real world and you'll lean forward in VR
as well that's called positional
tracking and is one of the most
significant differences between a higher
and headset and a mobile VR device it
runs off a smartphone like the Samsung
gear VR it's also an absolute must for
most things you're gonna want to do in
VR well 360 degree videos and pictures
don't take advantage of positional
tracking games do and games are by far
the most robust to use case right now
if you're not at least somewhat
interested in games then this won't be a
day one purchase for you are interested
in games there are 30 of them available
in the Akio store starting today the
rift isn't cheap it's $600 for the
headset and accessories alone and if you
need an oculus ready PC to go with it
you're looking at $1,500 in the minimum
for the whole thing now if you've been
excited about VR you've been keeping
tabs on it you've likely already been
saving your pennies and if you have been
you won't be disappointed if you're just
curious though you may want to check it
out at a friend's house but if you do
don't blame me if you run out the next
day to join the VR revolution this is
not a fad I repeat this is not a fad
this is a very real first step into the
future how's my VR face